Narrator: These are the Sharks.
They have achieved incredible
success as entrepreneurs
and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came from
humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Now they are investing
in entrepreneurs' dreams.
This is my mission,
this is my life.
Let's show these Sharks
what you've got.
It felt like I got
struck by lightning.
You better have
a ton of sales.
$2.3 million.
That's crazy.
The world needs this stuff.
You're asking me
to roll the dice.
Oh, this is nasty!
That's harsh.
I think it's genius.
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
I want to be romanced.
I'm telling you, this thing,
it's about to blow up.
Stop the madness.
You know the definition
of insanity, right?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
I am going to be
a fantastic success!
Oh, my God, I can't believe
we're doing this.
Walking in the park.
This is crazy.
High five.
Narrator: First into the tank
is a business hoping to make
life with
a new little one easier.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Hey, Sharks,
we're excited to be here.
My name is Ben,
this is my wife Ariel.
And this is
our daughter Maggie.
Together: And we are
the founders of PupBox.
We're here today
seeking $250,000
in exchange for
10% of our company.
PupBox is changing the way
puppy owners
raise their fur babies.
Nobody anticipates
how difficult and how stressful
bringing a new puppy
into their home can be.
We experienced this
first hand when we adopted
our precious daughter,
Maggie.
See, the problem is that
with so many product options
in the big box stores,
it's hard to find
the best products for
your baby's changing needs.
We created PupBox
to make puppyhood easier
for puppy parents
like ourselves
by delivering everything
a new puppy owner needs
on a monthly basis.
Each month, our subscribers
get a box that includes
five to seven products
that range from toys and treats
to grooming tools
and accessories.
A training guide
is also included
to let you know
what's going on with your puppy
and what you should be
doing to keep up.
Everything is customized
for your puppy's
developmental stage
and physical characteristics.
PupBox will
walk you through
every stage of
your puppy's development.
Through
the potty training blues...
Chewing on shoes...
... and terrible twos.
Give us one second
to pass out samples.
‐Oh.
‐Oh, my!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Ohh!
‐You get one.
‐Hi, baby!
This one's yours.
This is Ferrari.
Ferrari?
Loves fast cars.
This is D. J.
I see you, little pie!
This is Shanelle.
‐That's Mavi.
‐Come here, Mavi.
[ Groans ]
Come here, buddy.
I was gonna wear
the same exact tie today.
Mr. Wonderful, that's Cash,
and here's Cash's box.
‐Look at you!
‐[ Chuckles ]
And are these
therapy dogs?
Um, no not yet, they
could be though, some day.
It's working on the Sharks.
Kevin hasn't said a word.
[ Laughter ]
How much is the box?
So the price range
is from $29 to $39.
It is a subscription.
Per month?
Yeah, per month.
So it's $39
for a one‐month
subscription,
$34 for a three‐month
subscription.
So, Ben, I want to
write some stuff down
so, uh, I want to lose
Cashflow over here.
Okay.
Bring Cash over here.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐All right.
He doesn't want
to be with
the mean Kevin anymore.
‐Cashflow, see you later.
He's crazy about me.
Are you kidding?
‐Give him to me.
The, uh, average price
paid per month per user
is $30, and that's after
all the discounts.
I'm not sure ‐‐ I've never
had a puppy ‐‐
I've only had cats.
‐Ew!
‐What do you mean, "Ew?"
Um, I would imagine that
at a certain point in time
they might not need to have
all of these different
training things
or helpful...
Sure.
... um, brochures.
Sure. So we capture them
when they're a puppy,
as early as we can
during puppyhood.
And then once they graduate
from our puppy program,
we roll them over
into an adult box,
which is more of
a discovery box.
Ben, how long
have you been doing it?
So, we've been
doing this for two years.
We've been doing it
full‐time for a year.
Um, so far to date, we've done
about $580,000 in sales.
We're on pace to do
$800,000 this year.
So how are you acquiring
customers online?
How would anybody know
about you right now?
Sure.
So our customer acquisition
really revolves around
social media and social sharing.
Because they're puppies,
it's very shareable content.
So we have 75,000 followers
on Instagram.
It really is content gold.
We encourage them
to share pictures online,
so it's really
a snowball effect.
What's your background?
Sure. So I come from
a start‐up background.
It was a conference
production business,
but I worked in
content marketing
and business development there.
And Ariel?
And Ariel has over 15 years
of pet experience, so...
I am
all pet industry.
So I've worked in distribution,
manufacturing, import/export,
every single thing
you can imagine.
Ben, what do you think
you'll do next year in sales?
Uh, next year, I think
we'll do about $2.5 million.
We've been growing
at about 10% month over month
for the last year.
So we're projecting that out.
Consistently?
Very consistently.
I'm gonna give you
my puppy back
just so I can
look in your box.
Are you profitable
at $2.5 million?
Yes.
Are you profitable
at $800,000?
At $800,000 a the end of
the year, we will be profitable.
We just reached cash‐flow
positive two months ago.
Oh, you did?
Yeah.
I must say, you're strategy of
putting puppies on Sharks' laps
has really taken
the teeth out them.
[ Laughter ]
Look at Cuban.
ever since that dog peed on him.
‐He hasn't said a word.
Ever since that
little puppy peed on him,
he hasn't said a word.
‐Oh, it's so sweet.
Drool, not pee.
Love the dogs and all that,
but your valuation
is aggressive, I find.
I'll give you $200,000 for 10%
if it gets to $2 million value.
Why is it worth
2 million bucks?
It's not profitable to me.
$2.5 million.
Ben: The numbers
that we're projecting out
for end‐of‐year this year
and next year
are very reasonable
for us to attain.
And with, you know,
the Sharks' help,
we think we can really
do a lot more ‐‐
Guys, I'll clear
the decks a little bit.
Look, um, thank you for
letting me play with Mavi here.
‐Yeah.
I'm not a big fan of
subscription services.
That's just
a tough business.
I'm out.
‐Okay, thank you.
‐All right, thank you, Mark.
So, if I say to you, I'll give
you the $200 ‐‐ $250k, right?
‐Right.
‐I made that small error
when I was writing it down.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐You did.
Um...
Math is complicated.
But $250,000 okay for 20%.
I want a Shark discount.
Thank you so much, we really
do appreciate the offer.
‐Do, uh, any of ‐‐
‐Doesn't sound like
you're jumping all over it.
Uh, I just want to hear if
there's any other Sharks
that want to come in now
for an offer
if you'd like me to ‐‐
I'm somewhat interested. I have
the same issue as Kevin does.
Lately over
the last couple years,
I've gotten into this area,
with TurboPUP,
and I work with
PetSmart and Petco.
Um, I'll give you...
$250,000 for 25%.
Herjavec:
A worse offer.
I just know that
I'm gonna be in this
because I'm passionate about it.
And that's why I have
to add that,
'cause that's purely my time.
All right, Lori, Robert, do you
guys want to weigh in here?
Um, I love it.
Um, evaluation's
aggressive today.
We're aggressive people.
Well, I like that,
but I do think there's
a bit of a premium
for having a Shark on board
and getting a deal.
‐I ‐‐ yeah.
‐Understood.
I'll give you
$250,000 for 15%.
‐Wow.
‐Okay, great.
That's definitely
getting better.
It's moving
in the right direction now.
‐Do we have a deal?
‐Ooh.
‐And he's forcing you
to take the deal right now
before what I have to say.
I would love
to hear from Lori.
Do we have a deal?
Narrator: One Shark is out,
but Ben and Ariel have
three offers for
their subscription box
for puppies ‐‐ PupBox.
Do we have a deal?
I would love
to hear from Lori
if you want to want
to join in the deal.
Um, we'd also love
to get Sharks involved,
so if we could hear from
everyone that would be awesome.
No way in the world
will I get into this deal
with the other Sharks.
They don't bring any value.
The other problem is
getting a Shark out of...
‐They don't bring any value?
‐Excuse us?
‐That's harsh!
‐Here's the problem.
All kinds of bad things can
happen the longer you wait.
I was gonna go in on Daymond's
offer if he would've let me.
But you just heard
what he had to say.
Here is ‐‐ Here is why,
I am going to leave my offer
where I'm at because of this ‐‐
‐So, let's summarize.
Daymond's offering you
$250,000 for 25%,
I'm far more reasonable,
and you get...
‐[ Dog barks ]
‐... Mr. Wonderful for 20%
for the $250,000, and then
you get the discount Shark.
I would have gone in with
Daymond if he would've had me.
‐And I love the puppies.
‐You've got two Sharks
at the 25%,
which is a better value...
What are you
thinking about Lori? Why?
Well, you know that I am expert
at getting things into stores.
Are you gonna give up 25%?
That's ridiculous.
‐You know I'm lightning speed.
‐No.
So why are you even
letting them talk?
...every pet.
‐No, no, I understand.
But I think through influencers
and through social media...
‐Ben, $250,000, 15%?
‐Mavi, what do you want to do?
I would love to hear
what they have to offer.
They're offering 25%.
Yeah, they're negotiating
with themselves and...
‐Here on one second.
‐Lori, the only thing...
Are you guys willing
to come down on the 25%?
‐Too much noise.
‐You don't like my offer?
I want to see if we can get
as many Sharks in a deal.
I don't want to deal
with the other Sharks.
It's not enough equity.
I see this
as an online play.
I have a lot of respect
for Lori, but I wouldn't be
interested in this, and I'll
tell you why I believe that.
O'Leary: So, Lori just got
thrown under the bus.
I believe ‐‐ here's why
I believe my extra 10%
in regards to him
is of more value.
‐Well, that's interesting.
‐Let me, hold on Rob.
Let me just explain because
I want them to make...
I got to
walk my dogs.
I have a large
amount of relationships
with manufacturers, so the 5%,
I could probably save you 15%
in acquisition of product.
Number 2 is, I have
a very big passion for this.
O'Leary:
I actually speak dog.
You know what
that dog's saying to me?
"Don't do the deal
with Daymond."
That's way too much
equity.
No one's letting Lori speak.
I don't like that.
25% is too much,
and we already have
an offer on the table
for 15%.
They're just
talking over you.
‐I know.
‐I'm gonna get up in a minute.
I'm gonna go walk my dogs.
‐That's what they do
all the time.
‐They do. It's horrible.
See, you don't know
that at home.
‐You know what, Lori?
‐I believe in you guys.
‐They can't hear you.
‐You want to do a deal
with somebody who has a passion
in cars, money, or pets?
I'm getting up.
All right, you got a deal,
Robert, you got a deal.
[ Dog yelps ]
The puppy screams like a little
girl, it's like he is a puppy.
‐There it is.
‐That's good.
‐He's covered in puppies.
‐It's a pleasure, thank you.
‐Thank you.
‐Yeah, yeah.
‐That was a nice job, guys.
Ben: We're super glad
that we got Robert.
I really wanted to
hear all of the offers out,
but as soon as Daymond and Lori
started talking,
Robert was really
starting to get pushy.
Yeah.
And I mean,
he gave us a fair offer.
He did.
We asked 10%, he offered 15%,
so we couldn't not take it.
Narrator: In Season 6,
we watched
Nick and Elyse Oleksak
make a deal with Lori Greiner
for their cream‐cheese stuffed
mini bagel ball company,
Bantam Bagels.
Would you be interested
in 25%?
If you decide
right now with me.
You have a deal.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
Greiner: Hi, guys!
‐Hey!
I'm in Seattle today
with Nick and Elyse.
And we are here at Starbucks
headquarters for a big meeting.
Last year, Starbucks
tested us in 400 stores.
And this year,
we're really hoping
they're gonna put us
in a whole lot more.
‐Welcome to Starbucks!
‐Hi!
Elyse: The journey to get here
hasn't been an easy one.
The outcome of today's meeting
could lay the foundation
for our business,
for our family's future.
I'm trying to be cool,
but I'm really bursting inside.
We felt pretty good coming out
of that first initial test.
We want to discuss, maybe
going to a few more stores.
How about 7,700 stores?
All of our company owned stores
here in the United States.
With this increase in demand,
we are gonna get things going
in Brooklyn.
We have 40 employees,
two shifts, ready to get going
baking mini‐stuffed bagels
for everybody.
Nick: Before "Shark Tank,"
we did $200,000 in sales.
Now, two years later,
we've done $13 million in sales.
Welcome to the family!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Having this partnership
with Lori and knowing that
she's there for us
should help us
grow this business to
the size we want it to be.
It's everything
we ever dreamed,
and we're here,
and we're living it.
This is America, the is
the entrepreneurial dream.
Everybody say "Bantam!"
All: Bantam!
Narrator: Next into the tank
is an apparel company
geared towards
an under served market.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Hey, Sharks,
I'm Hunter.
And I'm Alex.
We're from Las Vegas, Nevada.
Our company is Barbell Apparel,
and we're seeking $500,000
for 5% of our business.
‐Wow.
‐Whoa.
We're redefining clothing
for athletic body types.
Hunter and I grew up
living an active lifestyle.
We've played sports,
we lifted weights.
We're doing anything to get us
into the great outdoors.
But as you can imagine,
with a booty like this
and thighs like that,
we could never
find clothing that fits.
[ Laughs ]
So we decided to create
a line of athletic‐fit denim,
chinos, and shorts,
tailored to fit
muscular legs.
Using high‐tech fabrics,
military grade stitching,
and a fit tailored
for active bodies,
our clothing will keep you
moving in 360 degree comfort
no matter what your day
throws at you.
Alex, let's show these
Sharks what you've got.
In normal jeans,
I can barely sit down.
With our jeans,
there are no limits.
[ Grunts ]
[ Lori laughs ]
Now, who wouldn't want clothing
that can move like that?
Athletes work hard
for their strong, meaty thighs
and want
to be proud of them.
Our clothing keeps them
comfortable, moving freely,
and most importantly,
feeling great about themselves.
So, Sharks, who wants to
take a chance...
Together: With our pants?
[ Laughs ]
We have samples to pass out,
and we're happy
to answer any questions.
Uh, can we answer
the question about
why you're worth
$10 million dollars?
Wow, we're going
right there.
‐Yeah, let's go there.
‐Straight in, straight in.
‐Hold on, hold on, hold on.
‐Let's get the goods.
Because I guarantee you
it's coming up.
Yeah, yeah.
Is this a lot of Lycra?
Yeah, it's 1% spandex.
All right, Kevin,
what was your question?
Let's go right there.
‐My question is very simple.
You better have a ton of sales
to justify this evaluation
in the clothing industry.
‐Well, stop.
I want to just
get to this really quick.
Why can't we talk
about sales, Daymond?
Because I like ‐‐
I want to be ab‐‐
You don't have
a 32 inch waist!
‐I want to be romanced.
‐Are you kidding me?
‐Yeah.
‐Okay, let's ‐‐
Kevin,
ask your question.
Tell me what your sales
are gonna be this year.
$2.3 million.
‐$2.3 million?
‐Wow.
‐Yes.
‐And you think
you're worth
five times revenue?
Cuban: That's not
the real question.
The real question is,
what's your growth rate?
Our growth rate
currently is around 100%.
Per year, so you expect
to do $3.4 million
give or take, next year?
Yeah, $3 million
to $4 million.
Where are the clothes
being sold?
100% online.
Where have you
done these sales?
So we founded on Kickstarter,
in, uh, March of 2014.
And so, um, I married my wife
in spring of 2014,
and because
the business was struggling,
we were on our honeymoon,
and I was staying
at a friend's house 'cause we
didn't have money for a hotel.
And it was late night,
on the laptop,
finishing up the details,
and we had a goal of $15,000.
And I was just hoping
we would meet our goal
over the 45‐day campaign.
And I went
to bed that night,
and I woke up and there was
already $80,000 funded.
‐Good for you.
‐$80,000?
‐Yeah.
‐Wow.
We had hit our goal
in 40 minutes.
I have to admit,
I thought every niche
of the denim market
was covered.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐I have never heard of this.
‐I really applaud you.
‐That first Kickstarter,
by the way, went on
to fund over $735,000.
‐What?!
‐You did $735,000
on Kickstarter?
‐You did $735,000?
‐Yeah.
‐On a percentage basis,
I'm gonna assume
that a healthy denim company
can make 15% pre‐tax, right?
Our margins are
a little bit better.
Our gross profit on
last year's $1.1 million
was around $700,000.
What do you think you'll do
on this year's $2.3 million?
Our gross should be
around $1.5 million.
Is that after
you've paid yourselves?
‐Um, no but we've ‐‐
‐That's impressive, guys.
An investor has to know
your getting paid
and all the employees.
If you normalized all that,
what are you gonna make?
Free cash flow for this
year should be around
half a million dollars.
Good for you.
Did we ever ask
how much the jeans are?
They retail for $149.
That's not bad.
And what's your cost for them?
Between 15 and 20 bucks.
‐Wow.
‐Oh, wow.
Do you have a problem
with inventory?
We do. A bad one.
Yeah.
Uh, the problem is that
we sell the stuff so fast,
we don't have the cash
to buy a couple...
To take a risk.
... to kind of ease it up.
And that's
why we're here,
because we need a Shark
to help us
get over
our inventory hurdle,
so we can get ahead of the curve
and actually meet the dema‐‐
Hunter, I know this
business pretty well.
It's a management
of inventory business.
It's very, very tough.
And it sucks cash
like there is no tomorrow.
And I'm not saying you can't ‐‐
‐You said it, brother.
Yeah. I'm not saying
you can't fix it,
but at a $10 million valuation,
started as an investor...
I mean, you guys are from Vegas.
You're asking me
to roll the dice.
And I like to gamble,
but under this valuation,
it's too big a risk right now.
Do you want me to tell you
what you're worth today?
What you'd get in the private
equity market valuation?
I'm sure
you're gonna tell us.
[ Laughter ]
‐We're ready, we're ready.
‐I know you need to know it.
And thank goodness I'm here.
I think, if you could actually
get a private equity firm
to invest pre‐money at
$5 million, you're a rock star.
I don't think you could,
but if you could,
that would be the max.
‐I think‐‐
‐We're here to negotiate, so...
We're here to make a deal.
Like, like I said,
we're good at what we do, but we
know the value you guys bring.
So, let me tell you
what I think about it.
I have 15 clothing brands,
all right?
And, um,
12 of them are dead.
The reason why I still invest
in apparel business is
they have to have
a couple criteria.
I want it to be somewhere
in the sports and athleticism,
but not denim.
I want it to be somebody
who has to buy
a new pair of shoes
every three months
or they've been doing yoga
and they have to buy
a new pair of spandex
every three months.
Denim, the more damage it gets,
the cooler it is, right?
So, you don't get to re‐sell
that type of stuff in my world.
‐Yeah.
The last thing I want to do
right now is denim, so I'm out.
Guys, I just want to point out,
on an after‐tax basis
for a clothing company,
you're asking 30 times.
Yeah, but none are growing
as fast as they are.
Yeah, but that is
an extraordinary multiple.
It's not the multiple
that's the issue with me, guys.
The issue is, it's hard
to create barriers to entry.
The minute someone says, "Dang,
but Barbell is killing it,
I love their clothes,
but I can't get them,"
then that creates opportunity
for somebody else.
I'm not saying you're
not gonna be successful.
Look, 99.99%
of entrepreneurs in this world,
if you told them they could have
$500,000 net cash flow
after paying themselves,
would cut off their hand
to get it.
So you guys are
doing amazing things.
The question is how you overcome
not being able to protect it.
I'm out.
Thank you,
we appreciate your time.
‐Yeah, thank you, Mark.
‐And congratulations, guys.
You guys, listen,
I give you serious props
for what you've done.
Getting into this industry
is hard as can be.
And you guys actually
created something new.
Where I don't think there's
been anything new in forever.
But I can't see where
this would be an investment
that's right for me,
so I'm out.
But like I said,
serious props to you guys.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Thank you, Lori.
Guys, um,
the inventory scares me.
If I was ever gonna
get into jeans,
it would be
the two of you guys ‐‐
I'll tell you this,
before you go any further,
is that we are ‐‐ we are good
at inventory projection.
I know what I'm gonna sell.
I just need to be able
to buy it.
And we have great
manufacturing terms.
We're really good
at sourcing,
and we can get our lead times
down as low as six weeks.
Yeah, Hunter,
I can't get there.
It's just more inventory,
more money.
You guys are great operators,
and that's
the greatest compliment
I can give somebody
as an entrepreneur.
Inventory scares me.
I'm out.
‐I understand.
‐Yeah.
So, guys, who can downplay
or even suggest you guys
haven't done a phenomenal job
in such a brutally
competitive space.
I mean, that's what it is.
But this thing's
gonna inhale cash,
it's not gonna be
a very liquid situation for us.
‐Yeah, that's the problem.
‐It'll exhale cash, too.
With our margins,
it's gonna be
one of the best investments
you ever had.
It will, but it will
inhale cash,
as every
clothing industry does.
As Mark said,
it'll exhale cash, too.
It's a very difficult deal.
I'm gonna pass.
I'm out.
I think the lesson,
and we've all learned it
together here today,
this is not Las Vegas.
$500,000 is a ton of money.
Had you asked for less,
you'd probably be
walking out with a Shark.
Good luck.
‐Well, thank you guys very much.
‐All right, guys.
‐We appreciate it.
‐Thank you guys.
‐It was a pleasure.
Hunter: It was very frustrating
to hear the Sharks say
that they wanted to invest but
get super hung up on the money.
‐And inventory.
‐You know because there's ‐‐
it's not actually
that much money,
especially when we're like at
a $2.3 million run rate.
Well, that's the lesson.
People come in here
with these huge numbers.
It's an all‐in thing.
Why risk half a million bucks
in an industry that ‐‐
it's just
full of dead bones?
Even big brands.
The big brands are dying,
trust me.
Narrator: Next into the tank
is an entrepreneur
passionate about
popularizing
a health supplement in America.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Hi. I'm Catharine Arnston.
And I'm from
Boston, Massachusetts.
And I'm the founder
and C. E. O. of ENERGYbits.
Sharks, you want more energy,
better health, slow aging?
Throw away those
energy drinks and bars
and get your energy naturally
by going down to
the bottom of the food chain.
I'm talking algae!
ENERGYbits are tiny algae
tablets that give you energy,
increase your focus,
satisfy your hunger,
they increase athletic
performance, and speed recovery.
All for one calorie per tab
and all from one ingredient ‐‐
algae!
No, algae's not pond scum ‐‐
well, actually, ha, it is.
[ Laughter ]
But it's also a superfood.
[ Laughs ]
Hey, algae isn't even new!
It's been used in Asia
for 50 years, where it's
a multi‐billion‐dollar industry.
And it can be even bigger here.
Sharks, we've been selling
our algae for six years.
Doubling sales
almost every year.
I'd love to have you join us
as an investor
because we have
an exciting future.
Would you like to take a look?
Um, Catharine ‐‐
Catharine,
what were you asking for?
you forgot something.
Oh, oh, that's right.
I'm looking for $500,000
in exchange for 5%
of my company.
‐You forgot that?!
‐Oh!
[ Laughter ]
I don't blame you.
This better be good.
Well, you're a very
impressive audience.
Now let's see it.
I liked her more
before we knew the number.
I obviously didn't
have enough this morning.
I guess it didn't
help with your memory
as much as you thought, huh?
This is energy bits,
and on the other side
are recovery bits.
‐Lori.
‐Thank you.
‐This packaging
hasn't come back
from China yet.
Okay, so do I want
one of each of these?
Yeah, yeah.
Now, can you eat these
all at the same time?
Absolutely.
I'm going with the SKINNYbits.
I'm not an energy guy.
Take some recovery.
I love the taste of it.
30 is a serving.
You need 30 to feel any energy.
‐But it's very quiet energy.
‐30?
‐30's the whole packet?
‐Yes.
I'm supposed to eat
the whole package?
Well, we recommend people
swallow them, but yes.
‐You don't chew it?
‐No, you don't chew it.
‐Well, I wouldn't recommend ‐‐
‐No, don't chew it.
‐Oh.
‐Oh, this is nasty!
‐I love the taste of it.
‐You got to swallow
all 30 of these?
‐You do?
‐Yes.
‐I love the taste of them.
Actually, they go down
very easily.
‐A lot of people add them to ‐‐
‐I wish you'd said to me,
"Don't chew them."
[ Laughter ]
It tastes like when I look at
the scum on top of the lake,
if I would lick that scum.
[ Laughs ]
Yeah, but wait,
wait, wait, wait.
I'm looking at the ingredients.
‐It tastes like kibbles.
There's only one ingredient.
It's just algae.
There is nothing else in it.
No, but in terms
of the nutrition.
ENERGYbits and SKINNYbits
are actually the same,
just different branding.
RECOVERYbits
are a different algae.
SKINNYbits, ENERGYbits,
RECOVERYbits...
‐Yes.
‐... all the same thing
inside the package?
‐No, no.
RECOVERYbits are chlorella.
There are two algaes.
One is called chlorella.
And that builds your
immune system, pulls out toxins,
including lactic acid, which is
why the athletes take it.
ENERGYbits is spirulina.
And that's algae
provides you with
energy, focus, um,
satisfies your hunger.
So, how do you know
it works, Catharine?
Because, it's been used
for 50 years ‐‐
That doesn't
tell us anything.
Because there are
100,000 studies
that have documented
the ecificy ‐‐ ethicacy...
100,000 studies?
Studies, yes.
Give us one.
Well, I ‐‐ well,
there's one on that fact that...
‐Oh, this isn't go well.
‐... uh, spirulina contains
aficosinine,
which is a pigment.
And it has been documented
to reverse the growth
of tumors in cancer.
So all doctors, all cancer
doctors, all oncologists ‐‐
Virtually no medical,
none of the medical community
really knows anything about it.
So, they don't know
how to read studies,
is what you're saying?
Where are you selling,
Catharine?
‐Like, what are you doing?
‐We've been selling online,
only through our website
for the last six years.
What do you sell them for,
and what do you ‐‐
$115 for a bag.
For a bag?
How about a package?
A package is $4.
What's your cost
on a package or a bag?
$40 all in for a bag.
And uh, a ‐‐
For a large bag?
For a large bag.
‐How many in a bag?
Uh, 1,000.
What are your sales?
Uh, well, our lifetime
sales are $1.5 million.
[ Scoffs ]
‐Oh, my God.
‐A whole million, huh?
Hang on, over 6 years,
you've sold 1.5 million?
‐Yes.
‐What did you sell last year?
Uh, about $300,000.
Have you made any money?
Every single penny
goes back into them.
I'm always redoing things.
‐Got it.
I'm always revamping,
I'm always learning
how to do something
better, faster.
So, why is it worth
$10 million?
John: Catharine,
why would you do that?
You've seen this before.
You've seen this show
a million times.
If go to a horror movie
and I see a black person in it,
I know that they're
gonna die first, right?
You know know
they're gonna die first.
You know already what
we're gonna do to you.
Why would you do that?
What I want you to understand is
what's different about us
is that we have created
the first mainstream brand
for algae.
‐Branded, right.
‐You're a branding company.
We are the first ‐‐ we are
a branding company.
Catharine, how did
you get into this?
So, my sister developed
breast cancer,
and her oncologist told her
she should change her diet.
So after helping her
research the foods,
I started learning more
about plant‐based nutrition.
And I thought, "My God!"
This was like 8 years ago.
This needs to get
out to America.
So I went back to school,
I studied nutrition,
and I stumbled across algae.
And found out it's been
sold in America for 50 years,
but it's never caught on.
And I thought, "What's wrong?
Why don't ‐‐ why doesn't
America know about algae?"
Because it's ‐‐
‐Maybe because it didn't work?
No, it's because it's never
been branded properly.
Oh!
So I'll tell you.
So I started.
I spent two years
doing all the research.
I went through bankruptcy.
I was in foreclosure
for three years.
I had my car repossessed,
my lights turned off five times.
I suffered
every single embarrassment,
financial ruin that
you can possibly imagine.
And I am unstoppable,
'cause I ‐‐ You know what ‐‐
if you guys don't invest,
that's okay.
Because I am going
to be a [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
‐I like you now.
‐Catherine.
‐Now I like her now.
‐You get brownie points now.
I'm going to be
a fantastic success!
‐Too many ENERGYbits.
‐Because this is ‐‐
The world needs this stuff.
And America doesn't want
to take algae
unless you package it
in a way ‐‐
That makes me more excited about
investing it, you know that?
How many more years will you
keep going, losing money,
before you take this up
behind the barn and shoot it?
Well, this is
our pivotal year.
This is ‐‐ this is the year.
Next year, we're gonna blow up.
If you don't
make money this year,
we're gonna
stop doing this, right?
No, no.
I'm never gonna stop.
Listen, think about
what you're saying.
I think the mistake
in your presentation
is not your passion.
You're gonna have
a very hard time, anywhere,
getting around this
$10 million valuation.
I don't think it's worth
$500,000 ‐‐ the whole company.
Because you don't make
any money and you have
a non‐proprietary commodity
that you package.
I'm sorry, I'm out.
This is my joy.
This is my mission.
This is my life.
I‐I will do this
for the next 20 years.
You know the definition
of insanity, right?
Yeah, doing
the same thing over
and expecting
a different outcome.
Right. Look, I've had
my lights turned off.
I've had to turn off my phone
because of the bill collectors.
We all
go through it, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But you keep on doing
the same thing over and over ‐‐
No, I'm not. We're now
going to retail.
Catharine, Catharine,
you're on a mission.
But I think there's just
more than a minimal disconnect
from reality.
I'm out.
We've ‐‐ We've never
been to retail before.
‐This is a whole new ‐‐
‐Catharine, there's
a scary thing about
you're going to retail.
So in your packaging, when you
say things like SKINNYbits,
you're implying that you will
get skinny by eating them.
Catharine:
That's just the name.
We don't claim
about weight loss at all.
It's implied by
calling it a SKINNYbit.
Yeah.
You need to be responsible
that you are not
deceiving the public.
And that you have claims
in which to back that up.
Yeah.
I'm out.
That's okay.
And I think
you should be careful.
John:
Is this good for everybody?
Could somebody be
allergic to it?
Can somebody get sick?
Well, everybody buys product
liability insurance, number one.
So you have that?
Well, we don't have it, no,
because we haven't
been able to afford it.
[ Laughter ]
Whoops.
And I agree with you,
it is challenging.
Um, I'm out.
That's okay.
Thank you for your feedback.
Catharine, what's your biggest
benefit of going bankrupt?
Um, it was a humbling
experience.
Well, that's true.
In business, the benefit is
when you do something wrong
and you lose money,
it tells you adjust.
‐Right. Right
‐You've been doing it
for five years,
you're not making money.
‐Right.
‐You don't make the product.
You're not a manufacturer.
You're not even a business.
Yes, we are. I'm sorry that
you don't think we are.
You're really not.
With all due respect,
I'm not sure
you're a business person.
I think you're a preacher
in the land of algae.
Okay. [ Laughs ]
And I'm not sure
I want to pray there.
I'm out.
That's okay.
Is there anybody else
in this deal?
Nope.
Okay, Catharine,
thank you very much.
‐Good luck, Catharine.
‐Thank you.
Thank you for your time.
‐Good luck, Catharine.
Goodbye.
Sorry, Sharks.
I did nothing wrong
with the valuation.
The company is growing so fast.
And we have
so many opportunities
coming our way so quickly.
I don't need
to convince anybody.
If they can't see it,
then that's ‐‐
that's unfortunate for them.
It's not unfortunate for me,
because I have
a growing business.
My name is Vance Zahorski,
and I live with my two daughters
and my wife
with my parents
in Hudson, Wisconsin.
Every minute of every day,
I think about fishing.
It's been ingrained in my blood
since I was 4 years old.
My product takes one of the most
over‐looked inconveniences
of fishing and completely
cuts it out.
Brush those pearly whites.
When my wife agreed
to go all in,
I gave up a six‐figure job,
we sold our dream house,
and moved into
my parent's house ‐‐
the same bedroom that I lived in
when I was going to high school.
Couple more boxes here.
I'm the definition
of a one‐man band.
I've driven from
Rhode Island to California.
I handle shipping, packaging.
Luckily, I've got
my family to support me,
and they help out when they can,
which has been
a key to my success.
[ Groans ] Grab one.
From the moment
I came up with my idea,
I've thought about "Shark Tank."
I've played out
the role in my head,
and every step that
I've taken has been with
getting a deal with a Shark.
And now I'm right at that point.
I'm so close.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Vance Zahorski,
and I'm seeking $120,000
for 20% equity stake
in my company ‐‐
Line Cutterz.
Line Cutterz is
a fisherman's best friend.
Now, I've been fishing
since I was 4 years old
on my grandpa's dock
in Wisconsin.
So fishing's in my blood.
I was fishing at my friend's
wedding in Florida
and accidentally caught
a 3‐foot blacktip shark.
When I got it on to the beach,
it thrashed around and got
tangled up in my line.
I needed to cut it free quick.
So I ran up to my tackle box
to grab my knife,
and it had fallen in the sand.
I stepped on it
and almost cut off my toe.
At that moment,
I had had enough.
I was absolutely
sick and tired
of dealing with the same old
rusty fingernail clippers
and dangerous knives
just to cut line.
I've even chipped my teeth
biting line the old‐school way.
Twice!
‐[ Chuckles ]
I thought, "Why not just
put a cutter on your finger?"
So I busted out
some welding putty,
broke apart
a dental‐floss cutter,
and handmade my first prototype.
The very first
Line Cutter's ring.
When I slipped it on my finger
and effortlessly cut,
it felt like I got
struck by lightning.
I had figured out a way
to cut fishing line
faster, safer,
and more conveniently
than any other cutter out there.
I knew it was
a million‐dollar idea.
Now, in just over a year,
we have done $280,000.
I got to show you
how this works.
This is 12‐pound‐test
monofilament line.
Pretty popular for
catching sunny and bass.
[ Gasps ]
This is 30‐pound‐test
fluorocarbon.
30‐, 50‐, 60‐pound fish
is what you catch with that.
50‐pound braided nylon.
You can't bite this
with your teeth.
All right, let's get crazy.
This is 100‐pound test braided
nylon fishing line.
You can catch 200‐ and 300‐pound
shark with this line.
‐That's crazy!
‐Stop the madness!
I can't cut my skin
with it either.
And the best part is,
the fishing industry's
just he beginning.
So, Sharks,
who wants Line Cutterz
to cut you loose to make
some reel [real] money?
‐Can we see them?
‐Wow.
‐Absolutely.
‐Great presentation.
‐Could we have a sample?
‐So I made special rings
for each one of you.
Lori, I've got
a bedazzled ring for you.
‐Bedazzled!
My Polish brother,
the white Polish eagle.
Uh, Croatia.
Croatian.
Oh, I'm sorry, Croatian.
‐I can't wear this!
‐[ Laughs ]
Yep, deal's over.
Daymond, the most fashionable
Shark, my favorite ring.
He is not
the most fashionable.
And, Mark, I got a custom
Dallas ring just for you.
That's what's up, baby.
O'Leary: So, you teased us
a little bit saying
the fishing industry's
just he beginning.
What other plans
do you have for the ring cutter?
So, it just so happens
that this ring works perfectly
for cutting thread, yarn,
and embroidery floss.
This one one single SKU
works in two
multi‐billion‐dollar industries.
How much does it cost?
All right, so the ring by itself
costs about $1.68 per unit.
‐For you to make?
‐Correct.
I sell it for $12 retail.
‐Wow.
‐And I have 150 stores
that I'm in currently.
Cuban: And what's your
wholesale to them?
Wholesale to them is $6.00.
We're 70% margin.
What about the big box guys
in outdoors?
Keep in mind,
we're less than 17 months old.
We're getting there.
I flew out to Bentonville
and talked to Walmart.
‐And?
‐We didn't quite
get to the price point
we want ‐‐
O'Leary: They didn't like
the 12 bucks, did they?
Correct.
They wanted to retail it
at $4.99.
But, Vance, you have enough
margin to sell it for that.
What was the issue?
Here's the challenge.
So, I'm a young company.
If I do that and I upset
all the dealers that I'm in,
and I'm picking up
dealers regularly,
and then Walmart
pulls the plug on me
and I've upset all my dealers...
Good for you. Smart.
...I've got a really good
margin, I've got ‐‐
Vance, I want
to tell you a story,
and I want you
to listen hard, okay?
‐Oh, Lord, here we go.
‐Oh, God.
'Cause I think
you're gonna appreciate it.
I too flew
to Bentonville once,
to try and sell
software to them.
The industry priced
all software $39.95.
And I'm doing $350 million
a year at that price.
The price of the computer
was $1,200.
I sat with the buyer,
and he said to me,
"We want to sell
your software for $19.95."
Next week, Walmart
is gonna change the price of PCs
to $999, and our opening order
for you, right here,
is $24 million.
You have 10 minutes
to decide,
your competitor's
waiting outside.
What do you think I did?
You took it.
Exactly.
Our sales grew to
$1 billion that year.
Walmart changed the industry
by pricing at a point
that they understood
would move.
Listen to that story.
Don't be a fool.
How, how old was the company
at that point?
It was in
it's sixth year.
Okay. I'm less than
a year and a half.
But you're a product,
you're not a company yet.
‐Let me ask you a question.
‐Well, it's going that way.
In a year,
I've developed a brand.
I've people buying
my apparel line,
which I think there's
a great play here to expand in.
‐Oh, no, no.
‐Don't do that.
This is, this is long‐term.
Not now.
I haven't even scratched
the surface with this.
The fact that
you've made them
and sold it to them
is a huge red flag.
Vance, I think you're
gonna get knocked off.
My dad loved fishing.
He actually had a product
that was similar to this.
He had a ring,
he put it on his pinky,
and it was like
a little mini‐sickle.
He cut line all the time
'cause I always got it tangled.
But mostly, I can't
do a deal with you,
'cause you thought
I was Polish and not Croatian.
[ Laughter ]
So...
‐Damn you!
‐I caught it.
‐It was your parents,
Polish immigrants.
‐Yeah, I'm out.
Vance, let me simplify it.
I'm not a fisherman.
You know, anybody
who goes into clothing
when they're just getting
started always scares me.
It's not really a fit
for me, so I'm out.
Well, I'm sorry to hear that,
but thank you for your time.
What are you gonna do
with the money?
Okay, so the $120,000
is gonna split in pretty much
key categories ‐‐
marketing, inventory,
and then I need help.
Like, I'm running two companies,
I did the website.
Those displays are built by me.
I cut off a Halloween arm,
cut the bloody stump off,
painted them silver.
[ Laughter ]
The, the signs ‐‐
I like this guy.
‐Listen.
‐All right.
I'll give you $120,000 for 40%.
‐That's ‐‐ That's a...
‐Steep
... a really good offer.
‐Ooh.
I really appreciate it.
Um, if you don't mind,
I'd like to hear
if there's any other offers.
I really appreciate that offer.
‐Kevin's left, Lori's left.
I, um, I'm gonna make
things easy for you.
I didn't like the Walmart
answer, as you know.
I think you should
reconsider that.
That's a ‐‐ that's a very large
distribution partner.
Are you sure you want to wait
till he finishes what he says
When you're talking to a guy
who's an avid fisherman
and somebody who sews?
I can help you,
or you can piss me off.
‐I know.
‐He has a point.
And I'm gonna cut
this in half for you.
Are you sure you want to go
down that road with him?
Because it may change
after that.
Narrator: Two Sharks are out,
and Vance has one offer
on the table from Daymond
for his fishing line cutter,
Line Cutterz.
However, he may
jeopardize the offer
by listening
to the other Sharks.
Are you sure you want to go
down that road with him?
Because it may change
after that.
I can go two ways.
I can say I'm out and make it
easy for you to get a deal,
or you can piss me off,
and I'll drop this price
in half.
You can say you're out,
and then I'm gonna go for 49%
because he had to
second guess me.
No, no, no, look.
I'm kind of indifferent.
I'd be happy
to screw you up.
On the other hand,
I'm a nice guy, sometimes.
Are you sure?
I've come a long way
and given up a lot.
I'd just like to hear
if there's any other offers.
Uh, I have
no interest, I'm out.
Lori, you're still
in the game, or are you?
I think it's genius.
I really like it.
And I really like you.
But if Walmart is offering you
a deal, that's a huge deal.
I think you should be
very careful
about not rejecting
a great offer.
And even more scary to me
is holding too high
of a price point
where someone can
undercut you so severely
that they'll
just kill your sales.
So, anyway, love you,
but I'm out.
‐So, who's left?
‐You're left with Daymond
with $120,000 at 40%.
The problem is ‐‐
The problem is
in a negotiation,
you become more valuable
the less amount of people
are in the room, all right?
And you took a chance,
and you...
‐Ooh.
‐You're gonna make him pay
a horrible price.
‐Daymond, is the tide shifting?
Ooh.
Well, I was open,
but because I've become
more valuable, instead of
raising the price on you,
that's gonna be my final
offer, without a counter.
Take it or leave it.
Daymond, is there be any chance
you would take 25%
for $120,000 dollars?
I don't think you just
heard what I said.
You would've had that shot
two Sharks ago.
I just wanted to hear
some advice ‐‐
I understand
what you're saying.
But now I'm the only person
in the room with you.
If you and I start
as partners and I ask for 40%,
that means I'm coming
with the heat.
Cuban: Just remember,
60% of a watermelon
is a whole lot better
than 100% of a grape.
I understand, and I have fought
and clawed my way here.
And to give up 40%
is ‐‐ is just ‐‐
I would've gotten
an investor right away.
I'm literally ‐‐
I've given everything.
And you were one of the Sharks
I came in wanting
to do a deal with.
I think we can both
make a lot of money.
Um, just 40% is...
‐Then make him a counter.
‐He did.
25% for $120,000.
O'Leary: But he doesn't
want that counter.
We just launched on Amazon.
I'm telling you,
this thing is just about ‐‐
I've done all the work.
It's just it's about to blow up.
‐Oh, you don't know the work
that's ahead of you,
which I think I will enjoy.
Herjavec: Vance, it's not
selling time, it's closing time.
I'm not going
to counter on it.
I need to know
that you believe in me,
and I will believe in you.
‐Vance, what are you gonna do?
I'm not gonna
take advantage of you.
He has no flexibility.
What are you gonna do?
You've got 15 seconds
to answer me.
Would you do 28%?
You have 15 seconds
to answer me.
30%?
You have 10 seconds
to answer me.
I can't do it.
Go to 1/3, just try it.
I can't.
33%?
Okay.
Yes!
[ Laughter ]
You are one of the guys
I wanted!
Thank you.
‐Congratulations, man.
‐Yes!
‐Thank you so much.
‐All right, man.
‐Congratulations.
‐Oh, wow.
Whoo!
Yes!
Mwah, mwah, mwah,
mwah, mwah, mwah.
Oh, my gosh!
It's insane.
I've dreamt about this
moment for two years.
I've thought about
what just happened.
And it just happened
right this freaking second.
Woman: Say it again,
you're on speaker.
We got a deal!
[ Screaming ]
[ Laughs ]
‐With who?
With Daymond.
Shut up!
Yeah.
I can't believe it.
Oh, honey!
Yeah.